hi ladies hi so how excited are we to
reunite we're we're excited this is us
really excited
you know but we are very happy to be
together yes I love it well let's talk
Italy it was the movie's so much fun so
I could only imagine it was so much fun
filming what's your favorite memory it
was
it was a real Adventure it was fun we
care for each other we'd made a movie
together before the first one and it was
very successful so you know we kind of
we had trust we had love we had the
foundation and on top of that that we
could just drink and have fun and eat
and enjoyed this very funny movie what
was your favorite Italian wine yeah and
men and that you know it was fun to look
at them
so men and wine they were all the men
were gorgeous I got sick at one point I
had to go to a clinic and I swear every
man there looked like Melissa Rani
Victoria gasman I love that yeah so very
much a theme of this movie is like if
not now then when so I'm very curious
with all you guys what do you still have
on your bucket list
I haven't been to Japan and I I want to
go to Kyoto yeah badly yeah and um
and you have to do that with Ted yes I
want to do that that's a great trip yeah
I'd like to go back to Kyoto I'm going
to put that on my bucket all right you
can come with us I've been
yeah me too I've been twice but I want
to go back everything goes um skiing in
Japan huh I want to go skiing in Japan
really badly I don't exactly oh why not
because I don't want to break my leg at
my age that makes sense that very much
makes sense so also if we're gonna go to
a third movie where are we going
well
we might go to Burning Man
or Hong Kong
we haven't decided yet
oh my God amazing and we're missing a
member Diane Keaton is not here so she
you know we have to have her way in on
yeah yeah where is she here she's making
a movie she's crazy you don't really
know where she is even when you're with
her you yeah but I do know where she is
she's in North Carolina she's making a
movie
Asheville what's the dynamic with you
for
would you say what's the dynamic with
you foreign
just laughing and you know what there
are also Pros there are also truly
wonderful actors so it's just mutual
respect
you guys do another film
what are you like are you hoping to
bring someone else on like who would be
a good dream cast member to join you
guys
we hadn't thought about it have you we
haven't gotten that far
we're on the location all right I like
it thank you guys so much thank you
thank you thank you